hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
we're starting off with a game called
please which is very polite for a horror
game but I don't imagine it's gonna turn
I shouldn't have taken all that LSD
before I did this oh boy Wow woo
okay alright oh my god ah that is funky
that is weird but I love it Oh duh okay
anyway hey a letter I have friends
oh that's not a letter that's a threat
okay so I'm think about a control panel
please alright okay
okay huh oh I'm the repairman
I'm repairman boy guy oh god this is so
weird
ah the sound is really well done in this
Oh
oh my god everything seems so weird we
won
creatures retreat and troops safe great
good we won against the turd monsters by
the looks of it okay good I'm oh my god
that was something wrong with that
window I should get to repair in that
someday oh well carrying on what heck is
that got a pipe pipe okay whatever
don't worry about that later I just
gotta get to this like junction box or
the fuse box or something somewhat of
that nature okay uh communication
kitchen communal kitchen not
communication kitchen administration
bathrooms barracks shelter alright sure
let's go up I can't go up let's not go
off me let's not go up you up he's a bad
eye who it's right what
oh okay yeah yeah sure yeah okay um yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right pardon
I don't sound too good
together we can do it if we roll up our
sleeves and punch that Slugger we can do
it didn't really do it one of these it
is one of these where is it this one
okay
I'm assuming that was the sound of
someone someone cheering in the distance
I may owe some party really drank myself
into a stupor hello okay please you got
it
I live to serve I serve to live
anything different donor no no all's the
same that ends the same rate ooh new
power source I'm betting it's good I'm
just betting I'm a bettin man and I bet
that's good there we go
teleport e alright so I'm looking for
some kind of a a big electrical console
or something like that one of these baby
not quite loud down ere stamp out the
abominable pool right okay
there
Hey
I don't know what I did but I don't
think I was supposed to do it Oh down
here oh yes I want to wander into the
jaws of slug death oh my god oh my god
oh who's that blunder is that strawberry
jam one of those I'll be really happy
about and the other I'll be really happy
about
all right that's great that was that
chair always there in the naughty corner
what a horror games always have a
naughty chair
oh no requested it well looks like I'm
getting a day off
oh my god damn it I was gonna go off on
the town bris some ladies please you
think that they can get better pictures
what are they doing them good all that
partying down there there's a drunken
stupor boy they sure it's broken but
through pulleys he'll understand he's a
buddy of ours and then after is we'll go
get drunk
all right prisoners of war whoa that
baby's getting started early in life
whoo whoo whoo tell me right here I know
there's some I thought I thought so that
was a shot of a poison all right so what
I'm picking up
it's these things right here
okay no never mind
no it's not Oh in here Oh
Oh
am I locked in here
whoa now look dinner
whoa
yeah
terminate Oh
very oh how very
unwove you ah another day another dollar
I can't leave okay another day staying
in is good oh my visions getting all
blurry fix eluded listen
okay what is that what what is that what
is that what is that what am I looking
at what is that that's a very whoo well
oh okay well that's a problem okay sir
problems problems okay oh hi um you're
not a slogan oh you're not slugs at all
the party politeness is a sign of
dignity not subservience okay that said
what please is all about really okay
that is fascinating fascinating cuz it
wasn't a horror game in the traditional
like boo jump-scare line of things but
it was just a fascinating terrible
experience not terrible isn't bad but
just like weird and surreal and hot men
I love that that was really well done
that was well done I liked it
okay great all right so this next one is
called tape
tape unveil the memories
okay hi this is so this one here's a
demo of what a game is could be a lot of
these indie horror games or demos of
concepts that are coming later hello
hello
not bad animation not bad graphics can
the incessant wronging stop please okay
hello hi hello oh hello hi how are you
you know I didn't take my time on that
one so I think that's my fault
Oh a nice crab uh idea I've gone to the
restaurant today I'll stay until closing
so I will be late dinner is ready mom
okay cool good no thanks mom mm-hmm
go on okay so I'm thinking the bases are
pretty good this game actually has some
like yep do it it's got a lot of going
on here fun okay
pills wine always a good combo I like
that okay all right for area
uh-huh well some jasmine food the
gleaming interest anyone I would never
Jason stairs okay all right el a lead oh
all right cool I guess I'll play this
tape
oh oh I don't like this color we begin
yesterday pah-pah-pah why have you done
this Papa mama Papa Papa mama okay all
right well doing this sure all right
don't know why we're here or what we're
doing but we're doing it and we're here
so that's good
all right that's a lot of floors that
we're flying down in this weird place at
I tell this force that door open with my
big strong hands ah okay
this is cool nice tutorial
I think maybe L hospital indeed okay
this is well done if this is
representative of what the final game if
this isn't even representative of what
the final game is gonna be this is still
really well done silence please okay did
you know that politeness isn't
subservience it's just dignity I hope
you know that it's important wait a
minute hang on a second hang on I know
my geometry I've seen geometry before
I've taken geometry classes I think that
something went a little bit goof here
some seems a little goof hang on wait a
second hey wait a minute hey come on now
what are you doing yeah what's going on
here hey stairs are that way right okay
I'm gonna go this way um ah nice
wallpaper very nice I owe you you scamp
you oh okay well I'm sorry
oh boy someone's big and someone's
breezy mama is that you mama it's me
are you gone you done
mama come on it's okay you know I don't
judge you for your hunchback and deep
growly voice and probably I think I saw
like tentacles coming off your shot Wow
okay right cool
all the exits are saying behind but I'm
always forward forward forward always
forward that's what I say ah
righty-ho huh I just got like evil
within two flashbacks when the goop
monster came oh sorry I used that
phrasing but you know what I mean it
looks like that room that you had to
hide away from the goop all of the group
all right cool good to know that's long
that's good I guess I should have
followed the paper trail over to this
one that would be smart
very smart very I'm a smart I'm a smart
here we go
never mind I'm not that warm ah I was
right about a lot of those details I've
gleaned a lot from just your shadow mama
your hunchback and your tentacles oh
mama
come give me a hug you got him
Kuki great guess Alton that's normal
guess I'll just mosey on boo were those
they're Cylons porfavor um you talkin
that I need to be quiet here is that a
hint is that a hint II whoo
is that a hint II whoo whoo that's a
hint II who isn't it oh that's cool that
looks really cool that looks super cool
I like the look of that that's cool
that's really cool that's cool
die Wow weird okay all right well then
that's also cool this is cool this is
cool
uh-huh yeah well you're awfully calm
about all this you shouldn't be Oh
- dad from area great great dad loved
his camera Oh
back before mom had a hunchback all
right hi
all right hang on a second here better
catch this on film okay so uh so what
about that when one door opens another
one closes
interesting
so just because I don't know if the
store is closed or open it seems to be
both so I'm thinking that maybe it's not
quite so close open it's not quite so
close opened if you know what I mean
maybe through this I can fear beyond how
about here secret secrets wait a minute
seems like I'm stealing time from the
teddy bear to get tape time
oh I stole time from the teddy bear yeah
okay I got tape time oh so cool
that's so cool I'm gonna take your time
give me your time give me all your time
oh your time has been stolen of a time
vampire will suck the time right out of
your time hole all right here we go get
ready to into a face full of time time
take that time you to take this time go
all the way get up there oh all right
who wants more sucking give me that time
yeah give me all your time you take my
time getting time all over it's really
cool and I just had to make it so weird
give me your time give me your time you
oh yeah you bought the wine give me your
time your time give me your time you
gonna give me your time hello Oh better
give me all your time okay all right
then well okay
okay cool plop that in there everything
is normal here all is that should be
Papa color
we began yesterday yeah alright what you
need time
Oh sagesse mucho que no sabes demi los
ciento I was getting quiero pero pero no
puedo a Tibetan siestas viendo este
video economic and a mucho tiempo
necesito get me at you the Syria un
podemos estar juntos okay
all right you need time papa I'm gonna
get so much time for you
i'ma get all the time
that was good oh man so good I love that
oh come on no god damn it all right
so that if there's any like website
about that game I'm gonna put it in the
description because I was really well
made that was really good
oh so into that I was so into it like I
was into it I was just there oh man and
the mechanic is cool I like that that's
a really fun mechanic anyway all right
fine so moving on all right so this next
one is a game made by Lix Ian yes that
very same Lix Ian oh yeah that's one
it's he made this in like a 24 hour game
jam and then he modified it and enhanced
it all that stuff dude for me dude for
me is that a nose it's not like the
shadow under a nose or is that a tiny
mouth because either way it's kind of
creepy it's either like a tiny mouth
smiling earth like the shadow under a
nose I think it's a shadow on her nose
but all I can see is a tiny mouth now
all right let's do this
oh yeah it was a nose I looked into her
eyes I couldn't say no do it for me she
said and so I did well alright then
ah hello I got a heart I did it great
ah-ha
to attack the woofle
what are wound food I'm sorry what I'm
sorry wait hang on
but what where hang on wait wait a
minute
wait wait
what what why do I have a knife wait
wait a minute okay wait wait what wait a
minute what wait wait a minute wait wait
wait wait wait a minute
wait what wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute so I might not if I'm
never supposed to stab people especially
if it's for her some tells me oh wait
wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa hang on
wait a minute
am I supposed to
am I supposed to collect the hearts or
not something tells me I'm not supposed
to
or maybe I own oh wait okay I've already
missed hearts so if there's like
something with like a completionist
angle to this I'm kind of curious hang
on pass by the heart so I'm gonna pass
them by oh boy oh okay all right
cool great hi oh are you not happy with
me are you not happy with me if you're
not happy with me just say I do it for
you I'd do anything for you except get
these hearts and kill these poofles I
don't know what a rueful is but I think
it's probably not something I'm
sputnik's what ow my legs whoa - how I
ohno ohno ohno hi hey babe I looked into
her eyes I realized what I'd done Jewish
for me she said and I did not all of it
but I did it oh can I live with myself I
wanted to blame her but it's my fault
the blood is on my hands
hear the sirens US blue dog dude she
screams in fear what hands in the air
she played me she used me before the
cops got close to me she whispers should
have killed all of them oh you got the
I got the puppet ending Wow all right
cool cool oh all right so there's
probably different endings let's go
ahead and do the good ending by not
killing anybody and not getting a single
heart let's do that
skills skills to pay the bills all right
well I'll wait for you I'll wait for you
forever ah all right and couscous dablam
my knees all right I made it I did it
hey I did it
Hey look good for me no instead I looked
into her eyes this time things were
different
do it for me she said I don't know how
but somehow someway I regained control I
was in the school hallway if you wanted
me to do it kill all of them I called
the police and she was arrested for
illegal firearm possession
she had an unlicensed gun inside her
locker I still don't understand how she
did it
if she used me like that and I almost
killed innocent people innocent
teenagers I almost threw my life away
because ver but I wasn't gonna let her
control me not anymore I'm finally free
I got the I got the walk ending I'm
[ __ ] woke uh I'm gonna do another one
that's it's so quick that I just want to
roll through a few of them okay yeah
yeah yeah do it for me do for me all
right yeah whatever oh and maybe I will
maybe I will maybe I will maybe I maybe
y'all maybe I'll just get all the hearts
what happens when I if I just get all
the hearts we [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me Oh
you worry too much guys come on it's me
we're talking about here me Marc EMU the
one it's me guys come on
it's me nailed it I'm the best I'm the
greatest I'm the greatest there ever was
greater than all the rest I'm the
greatest I love you babe babe babe it's
me babe babe I looked into her eyes I
see who she truly is
do it for me she said but I wasn't gon
do it kill them all she said she's a
maniac
a killer and I love her a person whose
only goal is to see people suffer and
die but I'm not like her I'm never gonna
be like her well for some reason I still
love her baby I'm in love with a
murderer if you don't do it I will she
said I refused then I'll start with your
first she's to play ow hey listen babe
you got the innocent love ending yeah
real innocent really innocent okay what
if okay all right so you got to get all
the hearts and kill them all then you're
also in love with her and you want
everyone who died wink pixel perfect
that's how I do that's how I do I pixel
perfect Oh
easy-peasy easy-peasy okay Oh rueful
dead oh no the whoo oh oh that's not
good
hello hi I looked into her eyes
beautiful do it for me she said I did
and I would do it again
she goes to her locker locker 17 and
takes out a gun
no witnesses she said as she walked to
the teachers room she was going to kill
everyone in this high school
oh god I love her
as the [ __ ] worst
oh my god okay alright that's as
horrible that horrible
a man but what uh what uh what a concept
what a concept I mean yeah
woof woof heavy [ __ ] but bonus bonus
psychopath ending
I'll probably killing but no love al
whatever I don't need it so yeah look
seeing uh well done in this one the way
to make a horrifying subject and
thoroughly disconcerting but that was
three scary games thank you everybody so
much for watching hope you enjoy this if
you want to play any of these they're in
the description below if you want to
check out more secure games I've got
them down there as well if you want more
of these let me know down in the
comments let me know down in to
everything down there all the buttons to
smash them until something happens keep
whaling your keyboard over and over and
over again until another three scary
games pops out so thanks again and as
always I will see you